kurz vor einem ausbruch das steht
möglicherweise der supervulkan long
valley caldera in kalifornien er ist der
zweitgrößte supervulkan der usa denn
anders als von fachleuten erwartet
strömt noch immer genug flüssiges magma
in das reservoir fest steht ein ausbruch
hätte globale folgen wie hoch ist das
risiko wirklich klicks um science in
future hier gibt es drei mal pro woche
spannendes sein wie das abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
er ist achtung 32 kilometer lang 18
kilometer breit und teilweise bis zu 900
meter tief die rede ist von dem kessel
artigen krater des super vulkans long
valley caldera es handelt sich um die
spitze eines super vulkans ein riesiger
gigant also in der sierra nevada in ost
kalifornien dieser supervulkan ist seit
rund
760.000 jahren ruhig doch erst vor
einiger zeit hatten wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler eine überraschende
entdeckung gemacht sie hatten
herausgefunden dass der zweitgrößte
supervulkan in den usa offensichtlich
doch nicht ganz erloschen ist könnte
diese schmelze ausreichend um einen
neuen super vulkanausbruch zu speisen
welche katastrophalen folgen hätte das
und wie hoch ist das risiko wirklich
dass der super vulkan ausbricht die
antworten auf all diese spannenden
fragen um noch viel mehr gibt's jetzt
hier breaks im science im future erst
anfang des monats dezember hatte ein
vulkanausbruch auf der indonesischen
insel java menschenleben gefordert und
eine riesige rauchwolke hatten die
umliegenden dörfer verdunkelt und
tausende menschen mussten fiel bis zu
800 meter weit vom krater rann floss
glühende lava dramatische bilder doch
solch ein schreckensszenario ist
verhältnismäßig harmlos wenn man es mit
den eruptionen von supervulkan vergleich
denn dabei handelt es sich wohl um die
dramatischen ereignisse in der
erdgeschichte gigantische mengen an lava
schließen dann aus der erde und das mit
verheerenden globalen folgen nach einer
mega eruption kann die erde in einen
sogenannten
spanischen winter verfallen doch trotz
intensiver forschung zu super programm
tappen fachleute weltweit im dunkeln
wenn es um die vorhersage zukünftige
ausbrüche geht immer noch nicht ist die
wissenschafts community in der lage die
tatsächliche gefahr präzise und
detailliert zu überblicken dazu das
alarmierende statement dass
nasa-mitarbeiter prime wilcox demnach
die forschung zur super will kann
weitaus wichtiger ist um die menschen
vor gefahren zu schützen als die
entwicklung von systemen die kometen und
asteroiden von der erde verteilt
erst vor wenigen monaten waren fachleute
in einer studie im renommierten
fachmagazin nature zu alarmierenden
ergebnissen gekommen demnach können
super vulkane nach einem ausbruch noch
jahrtausende gefährlich um aktiv bleiben
spektakuläre ergebnisse also und nicht
nur dass diese analyse stellt unser
bisheriges wissen zur vorhersagbarkeit
von super vulkaneruptionen tatsächlich
komplett infrage ein
katastrophaler super vulkanausbruch
könnte demnach viel wahrscheinlicher
sein als bisher angenommen
das internationale forschungsteam wollte
in der nature -studie unbedingt die
frage beantworten wie sich ein
supervulkan in ruhephasen verhält
spannend hier vor allem ob daraus klare
warnsignale zu ziehen sind die einen
bevorstehenden ausbruch vorhersagbar
machen das forschungsteam hatte den
supervulkan toba auf der indonesischen
insel sumatra genauer ins visier
genommen dazu sagt einer der beteiligten
wissenschaftler martin dani sieg in
einem interview mit sky news mit hilfe
dieser geo chronologischen daten
statistischer schlussfolgerung und
thermischer modellierung konnten wir
zeigen dass das magma noch 5000 bis
13.000 jahre nach dem super ausbruch in
der caldera einer richtigen ausbruch
entstandenen vertiefung ausströmte und
dann eine platte aus verfestigten rest
markt
wie ein riesiger schildkrötenpanzer nach
oben gedrückt wurde wir müssen nun
berücksichtigen dass eruption auch dann
auftreten können wenn unter einem vulkan
kein flüssiges magma gefunden wird das
konzept des ausbrechen muss neu bewertet
werden heißt also im klartext der
supervulkan auch noch jahrtausende nach
einem super ausbau aktiv und gefährlich
bleiben die risikoanalyse von der die
wissenschaft bisher ausgegangen weist
somit also überholt wichtig sei es nun
zu erforschen wie sich magma ansammelt
ok welchen zuständen er sich vor und
nach solchen aussprechen befindet denn
genau das sei entscheidend um das
gefahrenpotenzial von supervulkan
vorherzusagen dazu martin dani sich das
verständnis dieser langen ruhephasen
wird bestimmen wonach wir bei jungen
aktiven super programm suchen müssen um
künftige ausbrüche vorhersagen zu können
zu wissen die super will kann
funktionieren ist wichtig um die
künftige bedrohungen durch einen
unvermeidlichen super ausbruch zu
verstehen selbst wenn es also zu einem
ausbruch kommt ist die gefahr nicht
direkt gebannt wie die aktuelle studie
jetzt zeigt noch viele tausend jahren
danach besteht das risiko weiterer
ausbrüche wie also steht es um die
gefahr dass der zweitgrößte suchen kann
in den usa ausrichten der supervulkan
langweilig der bode seit nach 800.000
jahren vor sich hin doch möglicherweise
ist es mit der ruhe bald vorbei ich so
jedenfalls die befürchtung einiger
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
mit dabei unter anderem der us-forscher
rob nelson berichtet in der
dokumentation secrets of the underground
vor einer wachsenden gefahr die von dem
super programm ausgibt seiner meinung
nach gibt es einige hinweise auf eine
bevorstehende eruption unter anderem
spricht er von rauch sollen die aus dem
boden aufgestiegen sein und von erdbeben
die immer mal wieder auftauchen zudem
sprechen seiner ansicht nach auch
veränderung bei den gas emissionen und
den thermalquellen in der jungen
vergangenheit dafür dass eine mögliche
eruption kurz bevorstehen könnte fest
steht die fachwelt rätselt seit jahren
warum sich der grund der caldera seit
ende der 70er jahre langsam aber stetig
hebt ein typisches merkmal dafür dass
frisches magma aus dem erdmantel in das
magma und tatsächlich ein
internationales forschungsteam hatte vor
drei jahren 2018 bestätigen können dass
der langwelle supervulkan keineswegs
erloschen es indessen ist jetzt
potenziell aktiv die forscher hatten für
ihre analyse den kalterer untergrund mit
der hilfe der seismischen tomographie
durchleuchtet zudem hatten die fachleute
daten der knapp 130 seismischen
messstationen aus der umgebung
ausgewertet diese daten speisten sie
dann in ein physikalisches modell ein so
konnten sie letztendlich feststellen
dass ein teil des magmas bunter der long
valley caldera heiß und schmelz flüssig
ist demnach könnte sogar noch ein
viertel das magma reservoirs geschmolzen
seien und das ist nicht ohne zum
vergleich das reservoir des klang valley
superbrands könnte somit also genauso
viel heißes magma enthalten die das
obere reservoir des blues combo kannst
auch ein super film kann dazu schrieben
die forscherinnen und forscher in ihrer
studie
unsere daten sprechen dafür dass es seit
den letzten eruption vor 500.000 jahren
signifikante magna ein ströme gegeben
hat und die forschenden sind sich sicher
dass somit im magma reservates
langweilig supervulkan es aktuell
genügend schmelze enthalten ist um eine
weitere super eruption wie vor 760.000
jahren zu speisen laut der studie von
2018 aber besteht keine akute gefahr
dass der usd supervulkan in naher
zukunft ausbrechen würde das halten
diese fachleute für unwahrscheinlich mit
ein grund sind auch die langen
ruhephasen eines super fans 1000 jahre
mehr oder weniger spielen da keine große
rolle und für den langwellen supervulkan
gilt zurzeit dazu heißt es in der studie
dieses volumen und der relativ hohe
schmelz flüssige anteil besagen noch
nicht dass dieses mal auch europa ist
ebenso wichtig ist es wie das magma
innerhalb des reservoirs verteilt ist
etwas das wir mit unserer tomographie
mangels auflösung nicht ermitteln können
auch der deutsche geophysiker birger
gottfried lühr gibt in einem interview
mit facebook zu dass die vorhersage
eines vulkanausbruchs eine zitat
schwierige sache sei und weiter sagt
bürger mit mühe die wahrscheinlichkeit
eines ausbruchs in den nächsten jahren
unter der voraussetzung dass sich
aktivitäts parameter wie seismizität die
formation in gaza ptc nicht ändern als
sehr gering eingeschätzt doch fest steht
falls es zu einem ausbruch kommt wären
die folgen dramatisch in der ausbruch
vergleichbar mit der größenordnung des
ausbruchs vor 760.000 jahren sein müssen
wir sicherlich mit globalen auswirkungen
rechnen kein wunder also dass
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
weltweit schon lange an einem plan
arbeiten super vulkane wie diesen besser
einschätzen zu können oder gar in den
griff zu bekommen doch das ist fast wie
möglich denn selbst wenn ernst zu
nehmende alarmzeichen beobachtet werden
würden wäre nicht klar welche maßnahmen
und retten könnten die geologen society
of london beispielsweise hat in einem
gutachten über super vulkane
festgestellt dass keinerlei notfallpläne
für solch eine katastrophe existieren
solche pläne sind unabdingbar um die
menschheit zu retten die zeit spielt
gegen uns gefährliche super vulkane die
bedrohung ist größer als gedacht in dem
video geht es unter anderem um pläne
einen ausbruch aufzuhalten doch die
könnten die katastrophe erst auslösen
also anklicken anschauen und abonnieren
bis dann bleibt da